fait beau ça sent la fin de l'année
scolaire et mardi le ministre de
l'éducation du québec a soulevé une
question est-ce que trop de temps
consacré à se préparer à des examens
plutôt que d'apprendre est ce que les
élèves québécois ont plus d'examens on
ne vérifie
[Musique]
au québec les élèves en cinq épreuves du
ministère de l'éducation aux primaires
c'est secondaire en ontario deux aux
primaires de au secondaire en
colombie-britannique même chose de aux
primaires d'eau secondaire saint cloud
pas les examens donné par les profs
juste ceux du ministère au secondaire la
colombie britannique a réduit le nombre
d'examens l'année dernière il y en avait
cinq landes enlevé 3 ce qui donne de
désormais on évalue seulement les
mathématiques et la langue
en finlande il n'y a pas d'examen
nationale jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans ce
sont les enseignants dans les écoles qui
évalue les compétences des élèves
en france par contre les examens de la
fin du lycée s'étale sur plusieurs jours
ils sont si importants que les français
en parlent dans leur bulletin
d'information qu'on l'examen du
baccalauréat at il été créé et comment
at il évolué et qu'il n'y a pas
seulement le nombre d'examens qui fait
débat au québec il ya aussi la
complexité par exemple en 6e année du
primaire
il ya une épreuve de mathématiques en
huit parties alors ça dure plusieurs
jours est en demande beaucoup de temps
préparation si vous voulez qu'on se
penche sur un autre sujet écrivez nous